- Our next guest promises me
that you can make tons of amazing meals
while also eating clean.
She's a lifestyle pro
and the woman behind the popular
"Eat, Travel, Rock" blog.
Let's welcome Kelly Rizzo!
(crowd cheers)
Have y'all met before, Kit?
Have y'all met before?
- Well, I knew Bob very well, her husband,
and I'm so glad to finally get to see her.
- [Kelly] Oh, awesome.
I know, we loved him here at the show.
He actually did our season two premiere.
He opened with us.
- Yes.
- Yeah, and did a whole skit.
He was so fun, he was so cool.
How are you doing right now?
- First off, I wanted to
say he adored you, Kelly.
He loved being on the show.
He had so much fun with you.
So I wanted to start by saying that.
- Was just so fun to have around, man.
He was so funny. Yeah.
- He was a force of nature,
and I'm doing okay, all things considered.
It is a journey.
I've just completely been
focused on gratitude,
and being grateful for the
time that we had together.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Versus being upset that
we didn't have more time.
You know, Bob, he lived
a thousand lifetimes
in his 65 years.
- [Kit] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- And he truly changed the world,
and he made it a better
place, and he made an impact.
And that's really all you
can ask for in life, right?
- What a beautiful way to make
people smile and laugh, yeah.
- Makes me at peace with it, you know?
- And the cutest thing, everybody says,
"Oh, are you gonna move on and date?
She goes, "No, now Bob
wouldn't have liked that."
(all laugh)
- He'd want me to be
happy, but not that happy.
- I love that.
- [Kelly] Bob Saget's still there
going, "Nope, not yet."
- [Kit] Nope, not today!